yeah let's just let's just accept like
the moogs of course
uh as people who have seen this
stream before will know i'm um i'm a
sucker for
these stupid names
[Music]
and my opponent says huge fun good luck
reaching 2900 thank you very much
i do feel though as
since i'm like 32 69 now
reaching 2900 would be a bit of a bummer
but that's just me
okay so let's talk more play
uh what's the story here so he
sacrificed upon
he he's it's a bit similar to the
blumenthal gambit against 1d4
um and by the way good luck to my
opponents
as well may you one day reach 2900 as
well
so i think i should strike in the center
with
with e5 um move which has several
purposes
um obviously developing opening up from
the
for the bishop on on f8 so that
uh the knight on b4 would not be
not be hanging uh and also
it was not so easy to actually actually
take this i probably should go to b8
actually
knight a5 looks a bit looks a bit weird
um so he couldn't actually take an e5
earlier on uh or he could but it wasn't
that great because of queen
h4 jack and with if g3 there's always
queen to e4
um so it will be interesting to see what
he does now
now now he can take because
um
[Music]
because before when the queen goes to e4
i would had a fork on c2 with the knight
but
now he probably could have taken
because queenie for quidditch 424 you
can go knight f3
and meet that fairly satisfactory
satisfactory
yeah whatever i think that's how we say
it
um so he goes bishop g5
okay i'm just gonna go f6
try and keep everything sort of tidy
uh bishop g4 i think
not so worried about giving up the
bishop perez my
strategy is very much
dark squared based here so
i'm just provoking this
i think i'm going to eliminate this
knight i'm going play knight d7
and uh my opponent
does have some
activity but i think i have too much
too much control over the position harry
to be really worried
so this knight is just being rerouted in
a hurry to
[Music]
to d6
um so now i'm just gonna
put the queen on c5 probably
yeah queen c5 check
king 2 so if he'd gone queen e3 i think
i just would have gone b6
trying to keep the blockade at all cost
now i'm seeing that
i'm running short on time actually like
spending so much time yapping that
i'm actually
i'm actually a little bit worried
okay i'm just going to take this look at
fate
hopefully start invading
uh okay g6
and now e4 should win
take this back if it takes an f8 i take
with the queen and then
rookie 8 after greedy 4. and
this one as well is lost for him now i
have
now mccleary night up and he resigned
okay
good game but eventually the pawn that
he stacked in the opening
very much told since it gave me
a bunch of good squares for for my
pieces